it's all about overthrowing the old
stand it's all about smashing the
patriarchy
there was a gal
who this video went viral
i don't know how i don't know why
i don't think it is being facetious i
don't think it's irony or satire
i think this is the new standard i can't
even describe it take a listen
well i have this thing call it a little
quirk if you will i have hair
in my armpit i have it there for a few
reasons one
lazy two the patriarchy and three
your response to them tells me
everything i need to know about you
okay and for those who just listened to
that and didn't see it on the internet
this girl has shaved about two-thirds of
her head and then she has a lot of hair
on the back of her head and she's got
these thick mutton chops and
has armpit hair and you know is uh
has has made some interesting fashion
choices
she would appear to be on the left
i don't think she's right wing i think
this is her standard
smash the patriarchy and what does that
really get to it gets to this left-wing
view of the country
that is totally full of resentment
everything in the past is bad every
tradition
is bad and it is oppressive and it stops
us from being liberated
right and this is you see this with all
of these stories with
the the way they want to upend the on
the left they want to upend the economy
the way they want to
institute these racist policies on the
vaccine the way that they
want to reorder our political system
the way they want to reorder all of
these things it's because the past is
bad
and the new system is going to be
liberating and much better
now let's go along with that for a
second let's say seriously
i don't obviously don't believe anything
she said but let's say that all those
things are true
if that is liberation
i don't want it
does that girl seem like she's doing
well
it's not even just that girl she's an
extreme example when you go
to your thanksgiving holiday and your
sort of blue-haired feminist
cousin-in-law or something comes up to
you and and
starts yelling at you about liberation
and your politics and
trump or whatever you know
when you talk to these people do they
really seem like they've figured it out
like they're in a good place like
they're happy they're thriving they're
flourishing
no i don't think so that is not the look
of a stable grounded centered person
and yet there are a great many people
who are
who don't look or sound or shriek like
that
who nevertheless believe those kinds of
arguments
you know look they'll get married
they'll settle down they'll basically
live by the kind of conventional rules
and yet they will still buy into this
ridiculous notion
that the past and traditions are all
terrible and oppressive and
you know leftism is really liberating
they'll buy into it
they're being inundated with it by the
public health establishment by the
mainstream media by the entertainment
media
by higher education lower education big
tech everything
so they buy into it it's completely
[Music]
[Music]
incoherent